in its sixth sanctions package against
russia the eu said it would stop buying
russian crude in the next six months and
refined products such as gasoline and
kerosene by the end of the year some
member states are strongly dependent on
russian oil
but we simply have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
however as the eu requires the unanimous
consent of all 27 member countries for a
ban particularly intensive users of
russian crude like hungary and slovakia
will be given until the end of next year
to wean themselves off russian crude
both indicated tonight they would need
longer
despite the focus on gas oil is a bigger
export earner for moscow which typically
sells between 60 and 70 percent of its
crude exports to europe
in 2020 when oil prices were depressed
during the pandemic russia made 74.4
billion us dollars from crude exports
that rose to 110.1 billion dollars last
year
and with oil prices higher thanks mainly
to the war on ukraine it was expected to
take in some 180 billion dollars worth
of sales this year
the measure will also come at a cost to
europe which last year depended on
russia for 27
of its crude supplies
it is not clear where heavy users of
russian crude such as germany will be
able to access alternatives with other
big suppliers such as the us and saudi
arabia operating at close to their
capacity
but ukraine has been horrified that the
eu has continued to buy russian crude
this is what exactly need to stop
russian war russian aggression to
ukraine of course we in ukraine are like
maximalist and would like to have a ban
like as soon as possible immediately you
know tomorrow or even yesterday but we
do thankful for the european union for
this unity that they are trying to show
although there are some nations who have
some doubts and that has influenced
brussels where the viewers that this
move which was accompanied by further
sanctions against russian banks and
broadcasters simply had to be taken
in king sky news